the environment secretary george eustis
is with us hello tell us about this deal
well the challenge that we've had is as
everybody comes out of the pandemic the
whole world there's a lot of disruption
in supply chains some issues with labor
issues with shipping issues with
logistics and this latest uh problem is
that due to rising gas prices with a
surge in demand for gas in parts of the
world
this these two plants have had to close
because they've it's not been economic
for them to manufacture the fertilizer
that in turn means that there's this big
shortage of carbon dioxide which is
critical for use in
the poultry industry the pig industry
other food sectors beverage sectors as
well so we've intervened to to basically
uh support this company with some of
their fixed costs on a short-term basis
just for a few weeks so that we can keep
that carbon dioxide supply going and
give the market time to adjust and for
other supplies to come on stream how
much is it going to cost well we're i'm
not going into the final uh details of
that because i know lawyers were still
working on those finances
it's going to be in sort of you know
many millions possibly the tens of
millions but it's to underpin uh some of
those uh fixed costs so tens of millions
even just for three weeks
it's a big uh costly plant these are two
uh big expensive plants and it's to help
underpin some of those fixed costs but
it's going to be temporary we do need in
the end of the day we need the market to
adjust the food industry know that
there's going to be a sharp rise in the
cost of carbon dioxide probably going
from something like 200 pounds a tonne
uh eventually up to closer to a thousand
pounds a tonne so a big a big sharp rise
it's a small component but a critical
component of their production
and so the plant that's opening at the
moment is the one on t side but the one
on in cheshire that we were just uh
reporting from outside of that's going
to open as well um i understand that
both of them are going to to reopen to
bring those supplies back online the
challenge we've had is there is another
factory in the uk but that's currently
closed for maintenance there's also
another factory that we often get
supplies from in norway that's also
closed for maintenance so we have this
perfect storm of two plants closing
because they don't have a market for
their fertilizer
because prices have risen and two other
plants that are currently closed for
maintenance once those plants reopen
then we'll be back into a properly
functioning normal market could we not
have seen this coming
well it's difficult this coming because
um we didn't foresee that these two
plants would need to close we've had a
very sudden spike in gas prices um
there's a lot of a said turbulence in
global supply chains at the moment as
the world sort of comes out of the
pandemic comes out of lockdown starts to
get back to business as usual we're
seeing surges in demand for gas that's
having knock-on impacts that you can't
always predict and it is always the case
though that carbon dioxide there are a
few uh big players involved in it it's a
chemical process these are big chemical
plants it's not where you've got
hundreds of players in a an easily
functioning market you do rely
on big capital investment um typically
run by a few big companies and has it
been a happy deal or have there been
stern words
um look it's we it's been we've been
pragmatic on this and we know uh that
the the truth is if we did not act then
uh by this weekend or certainly by the
early part of next week
some of the poultry processing plants
would need to close and then we would
have animal welfare issues because you'd
have lots of chickens on farms that
couldn't be slaughtered on time and
would have to be probably euthanized on
farms we'd have a similar situation with
pigs so there would have been a real
animal welfare challenge here
and a big disruption to the food supply
chain so we felt we needed to act yeah
it
it's almost as if you're knee-jerking to
these problems though rather than
actually getting ahead of them you knew
that two plants were going to be closed
for maintenance you knew how much we
needed this co2 and yet we found
problems with the supply chain before
you've acted i suppose is what some
people would say well we've acted before
that problem presented itself had we not
really have you been well i think we
have because there are some empty shells
and we've seen pig farmers and other
people on the news saying these pigs
should have been already at market and
we can't move them because we can't have
them euthanized well look we have a free
market economy and that's right as a
general rule we believe that the market
should adjust to these and that
companies should come in this in some
ways is an exceptional set of events
where we've got two plants that are
closed for maintenance that's coincided
with
two other plants that have closed
because they don't have a market for
their goods we couldn't foresee that we
do know that carbon dioxide is a
critical ingredient we had previous
issues for instance in 2018 but it is
the reality that because it's um a
byproduct of a a major chemical
manufacturing process there are a few
big players uh that control and dominate
this market um and that won't change
when you have these sorts of processes
that rely on heavy capital investment
okay just final thought on that before
we move on to other things um you said
that the deal's still being ironed out
with the lawyers has um production
started again
it won't have started yet uh it will
take i understand probably about 48
hours to get these plants
up and running properly but obviously
we'll be working very closely with cf
fertilizers the company involved to
ensure that happens as soon as possible
an american company our prime minister
of course over in america at the moment
he's not coming back
with a trade deal despite the fact that
he was pretty confident that he would be
able to it does really look as though we
are at the back of the queue doesn't it
well look uh president biden's always
been clear that trade deals are not
really a priority for him at the moment
but look not with us certainly well
we've done 60 trade deals including um
an agreement in principle with australia
an agreement with japan which is a very
important trading partner we still very
much hope to be able to put together an
agreement with the united states um when
well look we we're not putting time
scales on it it's always better to get
an agreement we have one before the next
election don't you um we don't need one
before the next election but obviously
we would like one uh are you confident
of getting one before well we we are
confident that we will get one at some
point but it's just not a priority for
the u.s administration
isn't it it is for us and we don't we
have this special relationship still
well if you look at what we have
achieved with the years we have made
breakthroughs on things like whiskey
where we've dealt with the tariff issues
we've got access now for british beef
which is the first time in decades
that's something we've secured recently
we are in negotiation with them to get
access for british land so alongside uh
you know the bigger comprehensive free
trade agreement that we'd hope to do at
some point there are a lot of individual
agreements on individual products where
we're making some good progress you said
we would have hoped to do that sort of
uh in the past or i was still pretty
confident that we will get that deal at
some stage the the pm's but we can't say
what sort of time
we want to do a uh a trade deal with the
united states we've always been clear on
that we've never put a time scale on it
no sticking points
um i don't know it's just not been a
priority for the us administration i
think president biden's been clear um
was clear during his election campaign
that trade deals you know weren't going
to be a priority for the early part of
his administration but he is doing a
trade deal of course is new with mexico
and also um canada and we're quite keen
to uh piggyback off the back of that how
would that work
well look we don't rule anything out our
preference is that we have a bilateral
trade agreement with the united states
um and obviously we're also joining the
cptpp partnership in pacific and uh oh
we're getting into acronyms early in the
morning yes well it's a it's a
essentially a trans-pacific partnership
that's a an agreement with a group of
like-minded countries it's possible that
the united states will be uh getting on
board with that as well so look um we're
making progress on trade deals in many
areas 60 trade deals in place including
as i said
particularly this canada mexico america
deal do we want to get on the back of
that one as well we don't rule anything
out but obviously with any trade deal
it's the detail that counts um our
preference is to do a bilateral trade
agreement with the united states uh we
still hope that we can do that but
there's not a particular rush to do it
with any trade agreement it's better to
get the details of the agreement right
rather than be in a rush and president
biden's always been clear that a trade
agreement isn't an early priority for
him he said that during his election
campaign
um it would mean we'd have to have that
pesky chlorinated chicken there wouldn't
it if we did it it jumped off the back
of that deal um my director in my area
is going look
uh you wouldn't have to because the um
basically the the the import standards
would be set by the uk
so-called sps standards are set by us
there's a prohibition on sale of poultry
treated with chlorine and
no plans to change that at all what the
president is quite uh keen on is making
sure that the northern ireland uh trade
agreement uh continues as it is now i
mean how important is it that a u.s
president should be involving himself um
in internal trade issues in northern
ireland it's not got anything to do with
him
well look the united states obviously
was involved in putting together the
belfast agreement so to be fair uh to
him he feels that the united states has
an island agreement as well the northern
ireland uh agreement he feels he's got a
role in that i mean but what um what we
we want to help them understand is that
what we are proposing in terms of our
changes to the way the northern ireland
protocol works is all about upholding
the principles of that belfast agreement
where it's about protecting the place of
northern ireland within the uk
as well as making sure there's no border
on the island of ireland so um the
provisions that we're putting forward
the proposals we have are actually all
about safeguarding uh peace stability uh
in northern ireland and that belfast
agreement
u.s president disagrees um why is he
wrong
well i think um he's probably at the
moment just um you know reading the
headlines reading what the eu's saying
reading what you know ireland might be
saying which is that they would like the
northern ireland protocol to work in the
way that the eu envisaged um we think
he's wrong because the truth is that
unless we have a sustainable solution
that enables trade to continue between
gb
and northern ireland then we are going
to have uh issues and that itself would
become a challenge to the belfast
agreement so those who believe
as we do in the uh the hard one peace
and stability in northern ireland have
to make the northern ireland protocol
work on a sustainable basis and that's
why we have to revisit some of these
provisions around the way it's
interpreted and could it be a bargaining
chip for a trade deal with the us
um no uh the reality is that it's for us
to work out how we make the northern
ireland protocol work so he should
buttock really it really has nothing to
do with him well it's not a bargaining
chip in a trade agreement but it's um
it's legitimate for him to have a view
on it obviously and express that view
and we'll obviously explain to the
united states that's um you know
effectively what's what it's tantamount
to saying that potatoes grown in one
part of the united states can't be sold
in another part of the united states i
think when you explain some of those
provisions in detail it is understood by
the us government that that clearly
doesn't make any sense and therefore
should be um you know should be
revisited i'm guessing he knows all of
that um well look um it's a very
complicated um uh piece of agreement the
northern ireland protocol i'm not sure
he does fully appreciate all of that
we're obviously doing what we can to
help the the u.s government understand
that but principally that this is an
agreement
uh between uh the uh the northern
ireland protocols and agreement between
the european union and the uk that the
eu
said that they're open to engagement
discussion about how we can make it work
um what we're going to do about these
pesky protesters on the m25
well you know it is dangerous the the
the protest activity they have sometimes
deeply frustrating for motorists very
frustrating to get to work of course
very frustrating when people are trying
to get to work go about their business
there has been a robust police action so
far to date i know that early on some
questions were raised yeah but what did
you think about themselves is there
anything that you need well to be fair
my understanding is that some of those
protesters had glued themselves to the
road the police do have a duty of care
in that sort of situation
but there was some robust activity to to
remove uh those protesters but uh the
the problems continued we are seeking uh
to take legal action today we're
supporting highways england uh in that
what will that look like well i
understand they're seeking an injunction
that would give um uh powers for the
police to be able to act uh um you know
preemptively should that be necessary
okay and what about these people that we
and we're seeing being dragged off the
road as we speak some of those people go
back day after day after day how are we
going to stop them doing that
well that's why we're seeking from the
court some
you know strengthened powers to deal
with this particular incident we do have
legal processes around these the right
to protest is very important we protect
that but obviously when that protest is
uh posing a threat to the safety of
others uh we've also got a duty to act
and the police are acting and uh acting
robustly in this case and they could
find themselves with liberty being
removed from them i mean some of these
people are reverends aren't they they're
people of the cloth yes well look it'll
depend on the um the terms um uh of any
injunction that the court's granted but
what would you like it to see well i um
we're taking legal action i understand
to seek an injunction that would give
the police
stronger powers to be able to intervene
you know preemptively to stop these
protests happening so that you're not
getting a situation where you have to
wait for them to sit on the road cause
chaos and then have to remove them after
the event okay but what if they do and
what if they continue they ignore that
they continue to go and sit on the road
and cause all sorts of problems for
hours and hours and hours for people who
are trying to go about their business
what should happen to them well look
that it'll be at that point well
the truth is that if uh if people are
acting uh you know against a court order
then there's a there's a contempt of uh
court uh element to that but like i'm
not going to get into those
hypotheticals it would be for the not
really officers and legal advisers in
government to advise what should happen
at that point but obviously uh people
have to abide should abide by uh court
orders uh if they fail to do so then
they're potentially acting how
frustrated would you be if you were
trying to get somewhere like come and
chat to us on a
wednesday morning at 705 and the
motorway was closed and people were just
sitting in front of your car
yeah deeply frustrated so i can
understand how frustrated people are the
government understands that i know that
my ministerial colleagues in both the
home office and in the transport
department have been really on the case
with this talking to the police liaising
with the police and i think what we've
seen in recent days is some quite robust
police action to deal with this protest
and you support that yes great to talk
to you thank you for joining us this
morning thank you